إنه أسوأ كابوس لكل صحفي
أثناء بثه المباشر على الهواء،
اكتشف هذا المراسل أن زميله
قُتل في يأسه المطلق، فمزق
سترته
[موسيقى] قُتل
المراسل محمد أب و11 من
أفراد عائلته في
غارة جوية إسرائيلية مزعومة أفاد تلفزيون فلسطين
وهو من بين ما لا يقل عن 33
صحفياً قتلوا منذ بدء
الصراع في 7 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول، كما
تقول لجنة حماية الصحفيين، مما
يجعلها الفترة الأكثر دموية بالنسبة لوسائل
الإعلام منذ أن بدأت المجموعة
تعقبهم في عام 1992، كما قالت أندير
أبو حطب قُتل في جنوب غزة.
جزء من القطاع
يطلب الجيش الإسرائيلي من المدنيين الفرار نحوه
لكنه يواصل قصفه
يوميًا، ولا تزال العديد من العائلات خائفة جدًا أو غير قادرة
على الإخلاء هنا في شمال
القطاع، حيث تحاصر
القوات الإسرائيلية مدينة غزة، كما يقول الجيش الإسرائيلي ونحو
300 إلى 400 ألف مدني.  محاصرون، حسب
تقديرات الأمم المتحدة، عالقون في
قرد منزلي، أدت الضربات الجوية المتواصلة والهجوم
البري المكثف إلى تسوية
الأحياء بالأرض وترك أكثر من ألف
طفل في عداد المفقودين تحت الأنقاض،
وتقول المنظمات الإنسانية إن
آباءهم يواصلون البحث عنهم،
ولا يوجد مكان يلجأون إليه.
أنت والملاجئ التي أودت فيها
قوات النيران الإسرائيلية القريبة بحياة البشر
لم تعد
آمنة الآن، ويعيش العديد من أفراد الجين في شوارع
منطقة حرب ومع اقتراب القوات الإسرائيلية من
محنتهم تبدو أكثر
خطورة على نحو متزايد